hey guys how's it going welcome to
today's vlog we've got something very
exciting going on today number one being
brunch
we're meeting Josh Sundquist and Ashley
and Jenna's coming along as well we're
also going to another LCS match this is
week number two so far one hundred
thieves is three and oh I actually can't
who are they playing today that's gonna
be a pretty good matchup so we went last
week and I don't think I even posted
that vlog so here's some footage from
week one today we're here what do you
think Matt what do you think I have more
nervous than I thought I would be I
think I'm more nervous as an owner than
I was as a player I'm just excited to
get them on stage I can't wait first
match of the season play an optic I've
been talking my crash talk to Hector
back there well we're gonna be up here
soon so we should go inside you guys
might know this is Matt this is naicha
he is now the proud owner of 100 views
and today is one of the first matches
his team is gonna be playing here at the
LCS every night I'm so excited
because they're playing optic so you
guys know this is a fun time would you
guys say that your hundred these fans on
we have Matt we've been there since the
beginning we remember when you were like
what do you guys think about this name
100 feet two three I was like okay I was
like do i frame this text message down
give it to you like today
or these me asking you guys about it no
way it has everything so when you guys
go up like next on any literally any
minute okay
you should be up there casting all of it
but you did such a good job Call of Duty
eSports meets just steamed back I only
know Fela duty in Italy I believe I
believe
[Music]
[Applause]
I have to admit that I don't know a lot
about League of Legends cuz I've really
never played I've only played it very a
little bit but I can't say that this
game was so long Mac star playing if
we're gonna keep her in this game
because I need to understand call of
duty I gotcha but this is a whole winner
winner chicken dinner
sorry to enjoy the game is amazing yeah
congratulations to Matt this is a really
really nice
[Music]
they did so good I need some water help
me I still haven't played League of
Legends in about five years so watching
these matches I'm learning a lot every
single week I can't see myself really
getting into this game because I know
that I do not have the time to dedicate
to it this is one of those games where
you need time there is so much that goes
into it that it's super overwhelming
right you learn we gotta learn so we
gotta go pack up my drone and we're
gonna go to brunch because you should
always bring your drone to brush
thrown away to the match
I didn't even vlog during brunch I
filmed the beginning of brunch and then
I forgot to film and I have to show you
guys what Josh and Ashley got me it is
by far the best gift ever but more on
that very very shortly did you get
starting now are we late we're gonna
have time to analyze the snacks we're
not gonna be able to interview the
snacks
[Music]
vol today hello nature hello are you
clapping to tell me everything hundred
thieves undefeated so far in the North
American LCS in our first season ever
we are facing off against team called
cloud nine there are talented team there
are three and one I believe and so it's
going to be a really tough matchup vlog
is basically a compilation of the first
time we came to so this is like
to happen GG's took a cloud 9 they play
well that's good game was a hard-fought
match for shot okay by really
unfortunate that they lost but that's
okay
there will be more games now I have to
figure out where I parked because I
don't remember all found my car so now
unfortunately I have to go to the craft
store because I'm shooting a bunch of
cooking videos finally you guys have
been requesting them and finally finally
finally gonna be shooting some
Valentine's videos so to make the movie
magic tomorrow I have to basically bake
everything tonight so that it's easy to
shoot tomorrow so I'm at the craft store
and this place is overwhelming because
there is just so much stuff here that I
don't even know what to do but I know a
few the items that I need I need this
some clear piping gel these are a little
bit small for what I need them for but
it's gonna have to work because this is
the only size that they have here now
I'm gonna run in to the pet store really
quick to see if I can find Maddie a
Valentine's Day present even though it's
not Valentine's Day for quite a while
but I feel like because of youtubers and
scheduling content it's Valentine's Day
tomorrow
good behavior bedtime bear you know I
just don't think Matty is a good boy
lately look at these toys bad spaniel
that would get so annoying
biscarrat are you kidding me Wow oh it's
beautiful
I think Matty would absolutely look so
handsome in it I hope he enjoys it I
think you will
hey are you filming hey hi what's up
I stole a Butterfinger mm-hmm hi Matty I
got your presents what we're really here
for is what Josh and Ashley had
custom-made for Matty so we like to say
that Matty looks like a lot of things
Mark Twain George Washington at E is
presidential what is honey is that you
is this you if you were George
Washington is this not the best thing
ever we have to get him a costume we do
so thank you so much Josh and Ashley I
wanted to vlog at lunch but then I
completely forgot but this is the most
amazing thing ever like it needs to have
a special place 15,000 Esposito's
$15,000 Yankees 15,000 US dollars
playing HD trivia and pre-baking for
tomorrow's shoot
oh shut up now you're just insulting my
intelligence no bit of a problem
I always forget the cakes tend to expand
a little bit
oh I'm hoping that those don't get much
higher because if they do I'm in trouble
that is not ready I think it looks nice
it looks very nice limited edition
this is it guys I made the team whoa -
yeah thief in the night I'm gonna looks
a little bigger than this things
Justine Janice this is so cool thanks
Matt I feel like a real thief what are
we gonna get Maddie's Jersey Oh imagine
how cute I'll work on that
my name is it's a ijustine ijustine
ijustine that's me that's me don't do
lowercase so we thought oh then we do
not put an AI if they're a can't be
lowercase what did you do
he just wants attention he's been
playing for 90 took on a whole tree
he's like fortnight for tonight do you
like port night so I'm trying to do two
things at once I just finished baking up
all of my things for tomorrow that we're
doing and this no you give me that back
well if I ignore him he'll stop because
he just wants to be chase
anyway I'm trying to watch arrow I'm on
season 4 episode although I'm not sure
Oh episode 9 this is a cake decorator
scene so you can spin this as you're
decorating cake but I'm using it for my
laptop save him over here baking I could
just go like this and if I'm over here
doing dishes spin anyway I'm gonna
hopefully finish these up very soon go
to bed and we have a long day tomorrow
of baking videos before I go I have to
show you this picture of Maddie we put
him in under two thieves Jersey oh he's
just so precious now you're eating that
come here
sit he does not listen unless there are
treats involved bad boy I'll see you in
my next video hi
[Music]